hello we're glad you join us for this
live webinar vitamin D metabolites and
clinical revelant
I am Kristen present you lab routes and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
made possible by an open education grant
from agilent technologies agilent
technologies has no in has had no input
in the selection of speakers content or
mode of presentation let's get started
you can pose questions to the speaker
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the Q&A box which will open
when you click the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window questions will be answered after
the presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left this is an
educational webinar and mess offers free
continuing education credits after the
webinar is over please click on the CD
button located in the bottom left-hand
corner of your webpage and follow the
process of obtaining your credit I now
present today's speaker dr. Ravinder
Singh dr. Ravinder Singh is the director
of the Mayo Clinic endocrine laboratory
he has a focus area of investigation
that has broad applicability to the
field dr. Singh studies the application
of liquid chromatography cannon mass
spectrometry to clinical laboratory
analysis many of the methods that dr.
King developed are now considered
reference methods Jay have subsequently
been utilized for method standardization
efforts as well as to establish clinical
disease correlates which he is published
with his collaborators dr. singh's work
has directly contributed to improving
methods for the clinical diagnosis of
Cushing's disease
pheochromocytoma
and congenital adrenal hyperplasia he
continues to work to discover innovative
ways to better understand the uses of LC
ms/ms in providing patients with faster
and more accurate diagnosis dr. Singh
will now begin his presentation on the
Internet and thanks everyone for joining
as well the topic today I'm going to
talk to you today is real quick
vitamin D metabolites clinical relevance
I just have one this point is that I
work for medical of office which is for
profit arm of your nonprofit
organization Mayo Clinic so we will have
key learning objectives today the first
objective would be that we will discuss
the case of liquids which will also
highlight the complexities of item in
the endocrine system second objective of
the talk will be what are the greatest
issues allegedly working in detesting in
the peninsula lotteries and I would like
to finish with what is the clinical labs
role in differential diagnosis of
hypocalcemia and working in detox
facility let's start with the case of
rickets in a premature infant this
particular infant was born to the
c-section
mothers came for a routine checkup and
using Beauty check up on ultrasound it
was found that the fetus had growth
retardation and there was a normal
umbilical blood flow to the fetus and
the decision was made to have it
premature c-section for the delivery of
the baby when the baby was born baby
neurological functions were not perfect
and the echo score was only 67 when the
perfect school is 10 infant was given a
drug called 72 health and breathing for
various clinical reasons the infant was
also admitted to the neonatal intensive
care unit for medical management
one of the challenge in the intensive
care units for the interns who were
attending this for the child was that
the eyelid calcium was going up or down
as some interventions were done then the
calcium was low physicians air infused
calcium but then it went above the
normal range then they hide visit the
child then it went below it was really
difficult to bring calcium into the
normal range until a few months later
they figured out the cause and then they
tell she was normalized this picture
shows the actual picture when this baby
was taken to the radiology to make sure
that baby's feeding line breathing line
and other lines which was necessarily in
the intensive care unit work in place
and they were not misplaced during that
observation in physician notice that
there was the weakening of the bones of
rickets present in this protocol child
without wasting any time
the missions quickly started
supplementation of this child with the
wagon indeed and try was given 2000
International Union vitamin D in the
form of algal cell super old child was
also given similar special care which
contains good amount of calcium and also
some amount of vitamin d3 this
particular slide highlights that vitamin
D mainly comes from east of president
mushrooms and the d2 is mainly the plant
form of the vitamin but what do we need
to light d3 will go through the liver
index and water to 25 hydroxy vitamin d2
on a need basis one $25 off see what
immunity will be formed by an enzyme one
of our hydroxylate which is mostly
covered in the kidding
this slide shows the mammalian form of
the vitamin D which is called with
vitamin d3 most of humans get vitamin d2
by exposure to the sunlight but in some
parts of the world so people to
supplement by taking to the diet as well
d2 or d3 follow the same path by getting
converted to 25 hydroxy vitamin d2 or d3
and then either 25 hydroxy vitamin d2 or
d3 will be converted to 125 that has
also good Mindy to liquidly by using one
of her hydroxylase after the
supplementation cost this infant the
2008 of advocacy parole it was obvious
that the vitamin D levels in this infant
were above the normal in it and it went
up 220 nanogram per ml physicians got
concerned and we saw the supplementation
and as you can see with a green light in
2000 December look that is also coming
down so the F that we use in our lab is
called
liquid chromatographic and an aspect it
allows us to look at the total result in
taking shape to performs the red is
shown as 25 hydroxy vitamin d3 and the
blue is shown 25 hydroxy DT as we know
this purple child was getting d2 and the
red is d2 that was bent high when it was
soft and started coming down and the DP
was continued to take care of this
particular child as soon as the
intervention was made with vitamin D
there was no issue in the calcium
regulation for discharge the mix child
had a low 25 hydroxy vitamin D the 125
that hydroxy vitamin D levels in this
child were high but in the calcium was
normalized the 25 hydroxy was normal
the 125 also decreasing came to the
normal range and so was PT agent born
ugly and prosper days unfortunately
because of the premature delivery of
this child and other neurological
disability the child did not had a good
outcome the question clinically and from
a lab perspective is that was but it is
preventable in this particular ad let's
look at the modern system model is 25
years old gravida for three successful
pregnancies mother had a history of
chronic hypertension 2014 secondly
disease she had the previous pmc as well
and she was moko during the last
pregnancy and liberal history of
depression and she was a carrier of
cystic fibrosis when the radiologist
looked at this particular image they
were surprised to see that there were a
lot of system delivered and lot of
system the kidney and kidneys were
enlarged and this helped in explaining
what was the cause of cricket in this
child this also shows now that during
the last pregnancy mother's renal
function was not optimal and her
creatinine were high in the normal range
as you can see highlighted to the red
arrow so putting all this together the
vitamin d end of the system is very
complex and when the calcium levels are
low then the receptor of the parathyroid
gland which is called calcium sensing
receptors the parathyroid gland will
make PTH and beeping lee actually help
in resolving calcium from the bone to
normalize the calcium the circulation
PTH will also help in converting 25
hydroxy vitamin D to 125 dihydroxy
vitamin D by or
expressing 104 hydroxylase 125 dihydroxy
between D which is the bio active form
of vitamin D II will interact with the
vitamin D receptor into time and will
help in resolving calcium and phosphorus
and still correcting calcium absorption
so all this is complex mechanism the
written in D is controlled through
calcium and then cut PTH also has a
significant role in this pathway as you
noticed this particular case mother
won't have the polycystic kidney disease
and had so the treatment in this mother
would have been not what is human you
get from our grocery stores which is a
very cheap form of letting in genie
which is called alga Kelsey poor quality
Kelsey parole neither this mom would
have benefited from other you know
cholecalciferol so other end kind of
supplementation except that this mother
would have benefited by active form
which is listed down here in activity
and these zeros and they mean but Kelsey
try Alexa Kelsey trial and para Kelty
tile and then these drugs are very
expensive compared to what we buy from
the grocery stores so in most of the
population the supplementation with let
me get into a d3 is proficient but in a
rare situation like this case
mother will have required Kelsey trial
Rickett is a disease of the bones what
this slide shows is that on my left the
child has rickets and we tested vitamin
D level in this child and what indeed 25
hydroxy levels were normal in this child
but when we gave this particular child
the calcium that took care of the
breakage so the method in this slide is
25 hydroxy vitamin D or 125 diet rocks
within India and assembly molecules
in helping the absorption of the calcium
but is the calcium which helps in
strengthening the bones I would like to
now go to a second objective for the
talk what are the various issues related
to vitamin D testing the weather Wendy
testing is very popular as you can see
it here is in the media everywhere and a
lot of companies are interested in
giving you supplement supermarket and
like this particular you say half of
Americans are using supplements and what
mean D comes in the form of d3 called
the t2 so that means the most illegal
abortions happen next year when we do
the testing in humans so for the patient
care or to know the storage of the
community the our si should pick up both
d3 and d2 this slides for the reminder
that what is the difference between d2
and d3 d2 has this extra methyl group
and then this con cetera is born was so
that is absent in the day 3 otherwise
most of the structures between the two
is very similar what maybe go through
very active metabolism and is quickly
converted to various metabolites and we
cannot learn all of those into the
clinical lab because some of the
relevance of those metabolites is not
well established and there is no
clinical value so most of the time if
you are interested in knowing the
vitamin D storage and what a mini level
dilatation 25 hydroxy vitamin D is the
optimal test and that is only test
should be ordered and none of the other
ones listed on this slide the gold
standard method for vitamin D testing
right from the beginning has been HPLC
UV chromatogram example is shown here
and one of the disadvantage of this
method abuse is very laborious and
requires very long chromatography to
separate out 25 hydroxy from the
possible interferences it can have the
Muslim Labs now can afford SPLC combined
the tendinous spectrometry and death
examples shown here this F is less
laborious and has a repetition on time
and does allow you to give two separate
signals one for T P and B - and they can
be combined into the patient's record if
the total of the desire of the clinician
and the runtime is also less than what
you saw on the previous SPLC method
fortunately the comparison between the
HPLC method and LT pending mass spec
method is very good because more of
these methods do you require extraction
from the serum and release of the
vitamin D from the binding protein and
that is the key for a good method that
we need to remove the interferences and
we need to relieve the vitamin D from
the binding protein
this slide shows that method comparison
is good for both 25 hydroxy vitamin d2
as well as d3 l seeing aspects are very
cumbersome instruments that do take a
lot of space and this purpose light
shows that you need palms you need other
sample mean s back to make this happen
and this is the picture how our lab is
organized to accommodate various aspects
for testing of vitamin D and Nova
steroids and hormones this stepping does
require solvent and does generate a lot
of wastage in comparison mostly clinical
labs have automated instrumentation to
perform a lot of clinical testing by
using automated analyzers they are
highly automated they are less laborious
and
very popular instruments in most local
hospital labs so it would become clear
as we go deep into what was the
advantage of liquid chromatographic and
and mass spectrometry over the amino
acids there are two types of amino acids
at least which I'm going to talk about
in this talk one is called sandwich
amino acids which is very commonly used
for the large molecule with proteins and
this has really revolutionized the
patient care in the filter lab because
we have a very good sensitivity and
specificity when you hear sandwich amino
acids in comparison for small molecular
weight like vitamin D and other C boys
and drugs we cannot use sandwich
approach so we can adjust to antibodies
we have to rely upon a single antibody
and then we have to rely upon the
competition the label player which is
highlighted here the yellow star here
because of the design of the technology
there is an inverse relationship between
the signal and the concentration as is
highlighted on my right hand side and as
you can notice that the signal change at
the low end is written at all and the
signal change is not much at the high
end so the proceeding is far from
perfect and the low and then high end of
the amino acids for the small molecular
weight which are also called comparative
amino acids there is a very small
dynamic range where these esters are
applicable lesson the reservation and
because we're using single antibody
especially city could also below that
this antibody could cross react with
more vitamin T metabolites
if you remember we in this case we want
an antibody which should cross react
with retinol d2 and d3 so there a lot of
commercial amino acids available in the
market which are highly automated and
some of their characteristics are listed
in this slide here
what is highlighted in the red circle is
the specificity of the antibody used to
this amino acid in the first essay
listed in the top is that anybody has
the cross-reactivity the DT of the 52%
the second Isis antibody has a cross
activity for v2 MVP in the city under
person range - or an antibody right to
the beginning whether it was in the form
of radium in USA or the Ottoman liaison
had always had underbrush in prospecting
to the Teachman deeply some of the other
manufactures at one time had no cause
for activity with a teacher but that has
been corrected now so most of the essays
which we find in the commercial labs now
have equal cross reactivity to NBC and
by design HPLC method and LC methods
listed at the end of the bottom of the
slide you can set up your chromatography
in the Nasdaq can look for both BG more
deeply into the analysis this is a
difficult slide to understand but this
is called bland Altman plot between the
two methods and a perfect match between
the two essays if we were comparing
amino acid with the gold standard liquid
column of profit end in a spec or HPLC
then the solid line should be at zero in
all those open circles should be
frightened as we will not have as much
deviation as you see in this light so
the conclusion in the slide here is that
if the LC ms/ms is the ghost and are
compared to that this particular mineral
si has a lot of variability that cannot
be predicted in some patients you will
have a more recovery and in some
patients you will around their
estimation and that may not be the
optimum for the best patient care the
the laws of this region which has been
published comparing various ministers of
the gold standard ten domestic
technically and this is one of those
papers highlighted on this slide
this particular concluded that based
upon what si is used we can reach
different conclusions for the privilege
of vitamin D deficiency in your
population for example the black line is
showing which is the HPLC method that at
15 animals of below there is
approximately 10% of population which
will be below 15 animals but the same
population is tested by the radium
interested in the conclusion will be
almost twenty one twenty two percent of
population will be below fifteen animals
and if we use the automated analyzer
asset then our conclusion will be that
we will be always limiting the vitamin D
definitions in the general population so
the best estimator will be that all
those three lines are on the top of each
other so that we don't have any
variation than conclusion among the
patients and the physicians the last
objective for this presentation is how
carefully the lab helper position in
differentiating hypercalcemia to
avoiding the toxicity or other possible
causes I need to mention this case into
the different case now this particular
child was brought in your clinic from a
neighboring city and this baby was not
fighting well there was a war vomiting
and babies calcium was very high Kelsey
was 18 and medical smooth back and forth
between taken from 551 4 and the
phosphorus was on the roadside the PTH
was pressed less mistakes and own
ultrasound the worst indication of
natural caffeine doses for this child
I'm told in the history of this child
this specific child was being breastfed
and mother was giving something
medicine in the homeopathic group of
medicines and mother was also giving
some warm of some form of vitamin D also
and she could not remember the brand of
the Brittany at the time because the
calcium was high and mother was giving
some kind of what we need there was a
concern that maybe the child has a
vitamin D toxicity but the confusion was
it is known in the literature especially
adults that if the calcium in high lead
to vitamin D toxicity then the fossil
should also be high which was not
observed in this charge so that was
little exception to the rule so in order
to take care of the station or positions
of admitted the patient into emergency
and this patient was treated with a drug
which is not approved for adults
calcitonin which helped the patient into
being the calcium down the normal range
but as soon as the baby was discharged
from the hospital which is a sin that is
hospital Rochester Minnesota calcium was
also planning hi again the baby was
admitted again into the hospital to make
sure that hypercalcemia is controlled
baby was treated with another drug which
is penetrate so the F baby was being
managed clinically and being taken care
we ended up running this particular
blood sample from this child and to
everyone's blood price the vitamin D
level in this child was called 1500
nanograms per ml which was definitely
the toxicity range and that explained
the hypercalcemia in this chart
as you can notice here because that
supplementation was stopped but even
then it took 40 days for this look in
the white line for 25 hydroxy that we
need to come down from 300 to in the
range of say 200 none of them spurred
enough and the normal is good after 20
to 30 milligrams per ml so what led to
the toxicity in this particular child
we tested models blood and it was going
to confirm that mother's calcium
production created in are in the normal
range mothers vitamin D was also normal
so that could not explain high vitamin D
levels in this book a child even though
we know that this baby was being
breastfed as well but because mom didn't
have high so there's no way that what I
mean he was going for mom in the child
so for the problem with a mother mother
did say that she had been given
supplemental vitamin D and we told her
to bring that supplement to the clinic
and we look at that and mom was thinking
that she was feeling maybe a drop and it
should be in the range of hundred units
on the daily basis so this particular
what you see in the slide was like
source of vitamin D where this mom
mother was behaving and was giving to
this particular child when we tested the
vitamin D content of this with the
supplement we were surprised that intro
contained two thousand international
unit s was available it contains six
thousand international units in one drop
and mothers started admitting also that
insert the drop maybe once in a while
she was getting a full throttle as well
if you calculate the total amount of
gold is pretty good child they have been
getting that maybe approximately in the
range of 50 thousand internationally
for two months and that is what electric
questions in this particular charge
mother has stopped giving
supplementation and not this particular
young girl is being bellicose to the
physician and baby is growing back what
Wendy toxicity is not limited to the
children this particular slide shows in
end of addition we had with vitamin D
was in the range of 200 nanograms per ml
and this particular tool indeed did
knocking down the normal range new one
in one year so we put the biopsy of the
patient we were supposed to find that
the fat in this presentation contains
lot of vitamin D in the storage so
vitamin D is the fat on the world
vitamin and it loves to sipping of that
and that is what was going on in this
patient so what Mindy is available in
various shapes and forms and the patient
we just talked about a little too like
the top plates for them
he found a critical chocolate which
contains very high deliver what will be
and that is led to a question really
adult as well so there's a caution there
that they will be recommending more
supplements and you may have to watch
the doors which is prescribed or
recommended by your physician in summary
what you Mindy is the gray complex and
the Queen system vitamin D like any
other drug goes through various enzyme
attic processes so if we kind of go
through it vitamin D will get the motor
the 25 hydroxy vitamin D by the liver
enzymes 25 hydroxy waves and then 25
hydroxy lives or the 25 hydroxy vitamin
D will that can work with 125 guy has
also between D but when there is a no
need for 125 dihydroxy between D the
excess of 25 and 125 gets inactivated by
the enzyme 24 hydroxylase to the
inactive
but if there are patients in the general
population which don't have this
environment s 24 hydroxyl they are also
prone to developing hypercalcemia so I
would like to thank you for your
attention
and we're happy to take some questions
thank you thank you dr. Singh for your
presentation a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them into the Q&A box found
by clicking on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window dr. Singh will answer as many
questions as time permits
the first question we have is how common
is Rickett open the question up so the
linkage is the ancient disease and in
the modern developed world there's a lot
of supplementation in our glad food and
milk so we should not see kiss silicates
in the case which I presented to you was
a very rare form of rickets which
happened because another had a
polycystic kidney disease so fortunately
in the u.s. we should not expect many
cases of rickets and the same should be
true in other developing countries and
most of the developing countries have
realized and there's enough
supplementation going on thank you
okay thank you
my next question we have what is the
gold standard method for 25 hydroxy
vitamin D testing dr. Hector DeLuca is
considered one of the pioneers in
recommending research right from the
beginning he knew that vitamin D had
many notable likes and he believed in
extracting the sample serum of plasma
and then perform the acid either by
calcium binding proteins of amino acids
so the gold standard will be that any
technology which offers an extraction
plus the chromatography or LC ms/ms
because that increases your specificity
so that the chances of having cross
reactivity cut more than lowers so the
gold standard today would be liquid
chromatographic and and a speculation
that the clinical hydroxy vitamin D and
fortunately our CDC in USA has a
represented which was also developed by
NIST in us and we are the clinical labs
and the vendors should take advantage of
the effort they have put into
standardizing your assets
thank you Thanks what is the mechanism
of vitamin D toxicity
well difficult question here what the
mechanism would be that if it is over
those of what indie level and then our
body has to get rid of the excess
vitamin D and then one of the mechanism
is that 121 hat
oscillations we can work into 125
dihydroxy with Mandi and any excess of
1.5 Dada facility the D is going to
absorb calcium from the guide which
normally we absorb a small percentage
most of it goes to the waste but when we
have an excess of 1.25
dihydroxylation will be in circulation
because of the vitamin D in our storage
that could be one religious building
hypercalcemia or the vitamin D toxicity
great thank you
if there are no more questions I would
like to once again thank dr. Singh for
his presentation do you have any final
comments practicing with them all
everyone who was able to join us today
this is a topic which is entrusted to
lot of patients and the more we could
understand the physiology in the
mechanism how vitamin D works we will be
able to serve our patients our
corporations in a more educated way so
one should look at the literature what
are the various differences in various
methods and what it was we the best
method for what we will be testing for
the better patient care thank you okay
I'd like to also thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions we would also like
to thank our educational sponsor agilent
technologies for today's webcast this
webcast can be viewed on-demand through
November of 2017 lab routes will alert
you via email when it's available for
replay we encourage you to share that
email with your colleagues you may have
missed today's live event until next
time goodbye